voir dans nos mémoires du zinc je reçois
gérard darmon pour sa pièce a gelé mais
la pièce adaptée par patrice leconte du
roman d'anna gavalda avec irène jacob et
noémie kocher gérard darmon possible de
retrouver avec son album il était sorti
en 2008 pour ceux qui l'auraient manqué
il est en tournée jusqu'au 26 mars
la dernière date sera la rochelle à
l'auditorium michel crépeau gérard
darmon bonsoir bonsoir
alors dire un peu à ce qu'est cette
pièce je les mets donc une sorte de huis
clos a entre pierre et chloé pierre
c'est vous cet homme d'une soixantaine
d'années oui on verra qui est le père
d'adrien le mari de chloé qui vient de
le quitter de la quitter et dans cette
maison de campagne
tous les deux dans ces espèces de huit
clos ils vont se raconter elle va
d'abord raconté son chagrin et lui va
raconter son histoire d'amour pour la
première fois c est un homme qui
baissent la garde
oui c'est une espèce de découvrir
autrement ça peut se faire parce qu'au
départ je lui demande de venir avec moi
passer quelques jours pour là pour la
consoler pour essayer de cautériser un
peu ce cet énorme chagrin gala de cette
séparation
visiblement ça fait sept ans qu'est ce
qu'ils se connaissent ou les deux mais
ils n'ont jamais eu vraiment de contact
et je vais découvrir une
delphi que je pressentais alors qu'elle
va découvrir un bon père pas de soupe ce
n'est pas du tout l'histoire et le
considère comme quelqu'un d'assez du
raid assez insensible et l'espèce
d'ouragan comme ça et 2
et elle va découvrir quelqu'un qui a eu
une histoire d'amour qu'il n'a jamais eu
oser vivre c'est d'ailleurs le titre il
ya une question de clouer vous l'aimiez
vous l'aimiez comment je l'aimais et
tout était dit alors tout est dit mais
il ya encore beaucoup de choses à
découvrir parce qu'on n'a pas parlé du
personnage de noemi qui est mathilde qui
est comme un fantôme qui revient la
mission que je vais voilà la femme se
secoue de foot c'est cet homme qui n'a
pas osé qui a entre la passion et la
raison a choisi d'arrêter absolument
alors vous dites du théâtre que c'est un
exercice d'hygiène mentale
pourquoi est ce que vous savez le
sentiment que le cinéma ce sera un petit
peu la folie les apparences et que avec
le théâtre n'est dans vrai oui je
n'aurais pas non plus basculé de l'autre
côté parce qu'il y en a certains jeux
l'a entendu dernièrement avec mes
collègues qui faisait une promotion sur
une radio périphérique et le
présentateur bien inspiré lui lui
demande d'utiliser alors donc vous avez
eu un échec sur votre dernier film donc
vous allez au au théâtre maintenant
sous-entendu le théâtre c'est une
portion congrue et on n'y va que quand
on l'a des echets certainement pas non
il faut il veut alors je dis pas non
plus que le cinéma c'est le sait le
parent pauvre
pas du tout je dis que de temps en temps
quand on quand on est un acteur je vais
pas dire qu'ils se respectent mais enfin
l'acteur qui fait attention à sa santé
mentale ou l'âge il dit c'est bien de
pouvoir se recentrer
un peu au théâtre où on est un peu loin
c'est vrai de
tout ce qui peut entourer le cinéma je
parle des gens qui entourent le cinéma
quand vous êtes au coeur du plateau de
cinéma et vous avez votre personnage
vivant c'est la vie c'est la même chose
que le que que le théâtre il faut jouer
la comédie faut il croit qu être sincère
c'est compliqué il ya d'autres
difficultés suis autre technique mais
voilà parce que des fois vous avez été
sévère avec juste vous dites les gens du
cinéma où ils ont un petit peu oubliés y
avait un moment oui un moment de creux
98,2 dit milo a brillé mais c'est jamais
sait jamais
toujours la faute des autres y est il ya
aussi une grande part de ma
responsabilité
voilà oui bah vous mais ça arrive et
c'est très bien d'avoir des moments
comme ça des périodes
un peu plus calme et puis ça fait du
bien ça fait du bien parce qu'on se des
crasses de beaucoup de choses lego en
prend peut-être un coup mais ça fait du
bien mais il ya quelque chose qui semble
aussi bien décrasser c'est la chanson
l'attendait être sur scène et chante ça
oui ça s'éteint c'est une chose et je le
sens là avec la pièce le fait d'être
d'être allé sur scène et d'aller sur
scène pour chanter deux heures c'est à
décoincer quelque chose en moi je ne
sais pas quoi encore mais je le palper
sur santé oui surgelés né et il me
fallait ce ce challenge même si un mot
un peu galvaudé de la scène chanter i
moi ça me paraissait invraisemblable ya
cinq ans
c'était bon il a fallu ça rend pas
triste quand on pense au cinéma où vous
en êtes par rapport au cinéma lampard
d'un coeur des hommes 3 en production
c'est vrai ça je sais pas du tout sûr ne
suis pas au courant pas rose on parle
aussi des cité de la peur du 0 2 oui oui
pourquoi pas du tout et j'ai tourné un
film cet été qui a été interrompue quand
ben j'espère reprendre on peut aussi les
plus de pognon
et plus de blé pour sa première fois que
ça arrive le film au bout de trois
semaines on la vend la 45 minute de film
nous on reste 45 à faire un film
jean-michel dernière qui s'appelle même
pas mort
donc même pas mort et on va aller
jusqu'au bout et on va essayer de le
refaire et puis les projets de cinéma je
mette au cinéma non pas entre
parenthèses mais j'espère que cette
pièce va aller jusqu'à jusqu'au mois de
juin
il y aura de nouveau les concerts parce
que la tournée ils sont maintenant il ya
tourné une possibilité oui je ne sais
pas si je ferai pour mais j'en sais rien
encore cela mais en tout cas le cinéma
pour la pour l'heure le dernier
trimestre de l'année
c'est ça oui absolument il est là pour
cela
il est là pour ça il est là pour ça mais
j'ai pas trop plus d'agressivité que ça
je pense un bon micro je peux dire
bonsoir vos gros microbien rouge faisait
alors donc ce pitch une bonne micro des
années 50
là pour matérialiser un sujet
d'actualité sur lequel notre invité
envie de taper un peu alors quel est ce
sujet d'actualité où ces sujets
d'actualité rien il y en a eu beaucoup
je pense que vous avez vous avez eu
l'occasion de parler de football bien
sûr oui vous avez eu l'occasion de
parler
vaccin la grippe a donné l'occasion
qu'on n'est pas de parler on les a mais
ce qui nous intéresse c'est gérard
darmon qu'est ce que gérard darmon à
dire c'est que sur leur presse sur le
sur le reçu raymond domenech par exemple
voilà j'en étonné plus d'un mais je suis
totalement pour
je le défend bec et ongles
je crois que c'est un homme et je le dis
toujours qu'ils étaient trop intelligent
pour sa charge
je pense qu'il a parlé aux journalistes
sportifs comme un miroir absolument pas
déformant et qu'ils ont vu en lui
justement ce qu'ils étaient donc des
gens qui parfois tape dans les jambes
tape dans le dos non pas une envergure
exceptionnelle disent beaucoup de
conneries
et comme chaque française chacun a envie
d'être dette d'exceller d'être
sélectionneur hélas à 60 millions le
résultat des courses il a quand même
qualifié la france en finale de la coupe
du monde jusqu'en finale la coupe du
monde pour un championnat d'europe et on
est encore qualifiée pour la coupe du
monde
et si on arrive en finale et qu'on la
gagne j'aimerais être là pour pourvoir
les on a déjà annoncé la liste quasiment
des ddc successeur mais je trouve ça
d'une bêtise ça alors ça c'est l'autre
escalopes le lapsus est révélateur
ce sont des erreurs psychologique on se
demande parfois à quoi ils sont nourris
ces gens là je comprends pas un
président de fédération
10 passes à 6 mois al avance c'est
démoralisant nom d'un peu de pédagogie
pas laissons le laissons le travailler
ce sujet raymond on n'a pas parlé de la
grippe on n'a pas parlé on n'a pas parlé
des visites étaient expulsés on n'a pas
parlé de la deûle à la burqa comme ça je
vais je vais pas enfoncer une porte
ouverte en disant oui mais peut-être
mais c'est compliqué mais ça devrait pas
et c'est alors que profondément
on a quand même envie de dire enlève le
ton truc enlève le je t'en supplie que
ceux de voilà alors parfois je comprends
les arguments de de copé par exemple des
clones homme de droite plutôt
intelligente d'une licence on sans
aucune ironie et qui parle de qui dit
que c'est vrai qu'on a on a besoin de
ces docteurs et puis je comprend parfois
d'autres l'homme de gauche qui eux qui
sont pour le pour le respect absolu tout
en disant que par rapport à la femme à
la condition de la femme dont voyez ce
sont nous met devant des problèmes et
surtout on nous demande d'avoir une
opinion sur tout quoi
est nuancée me chercher parce qu'on
vient nous chercher voilà la cgm bien
peu quand ça ça se tétanise
alors donc se siffler oui c'est
l'occasion pour nous de déterrer si on
est un petit peu comme ça pervers et
chroniques qui sont en défaveur de notre
invité bon enfant c'est dans les années
occupent cible mais ce monde ses amours
et confusion de patrick braoudé c'était
en 1996 amour et confusion mara ont fait
on fait chacun fait avec gérard darmon
valeria bruni tedeschi patrie kristin
scott thomas et patrick braoudé
donc c'est une critique des
inrockuptibles 39 ans 96 on a dû
remonter un portrait de folie vielles
nicklausse amour et confusion balourd et
vraiment qu'on serait plus juste patrick
braoudé remet le couvert sur les
relations hommes femmes
après avoir traité la rupture génial mes
parents divorcent et la grossesse neuf
mois cette fois il accommode la
rencontre et la séduction en général
d'une sauce franchement indigeste on a
du mal pour kristin scott thomas
la lia bruni tedeschi absolument
martyrisé par la coiffeuse j'aime au
jade monde et gérard darmon qui répète
en boucle que sa principale réplique des
nichons il hérite d'euros l'impossible
est terriblement vulgaire alors que
braoudé
comme par hasard c'est un peu bien servi
voilà hypocrite fatiguant nul avoir
seulement par ceux qui n'auraient pas
encore compris le sens de l'expression
hétéro bof
bon je range assez alors on vous avait
dit oui en même temps comment ça vous
avez dit bon bah oui giron fait des
erreurs
c'est son opinion je respect que j'avais
j'aurais pu dans un style un peu moins
violent dire la même chose c'est vrai il
ya des films qu'on fait qu'on trouvera t
moi j'avais bien le travail de braoudé
jusqu'à neuf mois et c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai accepté de faire
simple quand j'ai vu le résultat
d'abord je n'ai pas osé lui dire qu'il
se trompait de casting en réalité ils
auraient dû prendre mon rôle et moi le
sien parce que n'est pas woody allen qui
veut on peut pas avoir les plus belles
gonzesses du monde même quand on est il
ya coup d'y aller un petit peu et peut
voler lui il faut qu'il s'est compliqué
donc il y avait c'est un rôle d'un
séducteur d'un mec qui est je me voyais
plus dans le couple crise et avec
kristin scott thomas qu que lui mais bon
le tournage s'est très très bien passé
comme quoi on peut faire un film où
s'entend tous très bien et on s'aime
tous énormément serait peu se respecte
énormément et ça peut être une grosse
daube à l'arrivée il faut il faut avoir
le courage de le dire quand vous avez
entendu le titre du magazine lsa fait
aulas pourquoi parce que vous avez pas
aux maisons ils ont la dent très dure
les inrockuptibles c'est comme ça c'est
un peu sur vous non non non pas du tout
généralement ils ont été plutôt plutôt
sympathique quant à la musique
oui avec moi un samassa massa m'a étonné
[Musique]
par exemple on sait que bon quand on a
un mauvais libé c'est plutôt
est ce comme ça il ya des choses comme
ça qui à la longue se disent dans le
métier la météo de la critique on s'est
un peu voilà bon et puis vous voulez que
je fasse une confidence c'est que voyez
vous m'avez lu cette critique
je ne lis aucune critique je voulais je
vous le jure j'ai touché au monde je ne
lis pas de critiques qu'elles soient
bonnes ou mauvaises
je m'en fous et je pense que mon arme
absolue
ils m'ont ils vont continuer à mon goût
loire c'est l'indifférence
[Musique]
le défense de fumer la drogue a écrit en
arabe et en français s'il y en a vu des
haricots
voilà oui sinon il ya des choses il ya
plein de couleurs il ya des visages
aussi j'aime bien filmé les visages les
regards sur tout alors voilà au-delà de
ces de ce goût pour les regards l'idée
c'est de nous emmener dans un moment de
votre intimité
mais abc moment un peu tendre convient
ou avec ses enfants ou dans le cadre de
son métier je t'écoute ravasi alors quel
papa poule et gardes allemands parce
qu'il est papa paul
écoute papa poule probablement oui oui
oui probablement
c'est con mais c'est compliqué c'est
très compliqué de l'éducation c'est
fascinant c'est un moteur une énergie ce
qui nous amène mais sait que c'est
compliqué qu avant
j'essaie de faire au mieux et comment
les projette on les voit y en a déjà
quand mes passions avec oui oui enfin
bon c'est moi jeune fils à 12 ans par
exemple il est illettré batterie hip hop
fait des cours et baskets donc celui les
dents les remet donc dans l'air du temps
nafi 15 ans et qui est belle comme le
jour je sais pas ce qu'elle veut faire
mais par exemple comme si elle était
attirée par ce métier de saltimbanque la
cac
je sais que nous déjà je sais que non
donc ça c'est déjà ça me met ça me
rassure un peu mais ça me renvoie à
moins lorsque j'y faisais mes parents je
vais voilà j'ai arrêté j'ai arrêté
l'école je me suis inscrit dans un cours
d'informatique
j'avais déjà fait 17 ans 18 ans et je
rentrais c'est l'année du bac
je me suis barré ils l'ont pris avec le
recul ils ont pris merveilleusement bien
quoi et si ça arrivait aujourd'hui aussi
bien non et non je crois pas très
franchement je le redis c'est je le
redis c'est quand même c'est pas la
guerre dehors mais c'est c'est compliqué
alors ou bien voulez aller à cette
guerre qui n'en est pas une
avec un lance pierre bon petit
lance-pierre avec des petites des petits
cailloux qui font bien mal quand on les
prend
ou bien vous avez des ce code est ce que
vous vous la fête
lescott ça veut dire de ça veut dire
développer la culture l'intelligence
aller plus loin possible
voilà donc élever ses enfants c'est un
peu comme un soir de première tous les
soirs à cette traque et en maintenant
c'est justement ce soir de première
on sent tout proche dans cette pièce je
l'aimais adapté par patrice leconte
2l'ouvrage la naa gavalda avec irène
jacob et noémie kocher
c'est au théâtre de l'atelier et ça
commence ce soir et alors en ce qui
concerne à celle oui à chansons le tour
on sème en tournée jusqu'au 26 mars
la dernière date c'est la rochelle à
l'auditorium michel crépeau voilà
beaucoup d'occasions de partager le
plaisir d'être avec gérard darmon en
tout cas pendant c'était un plaisir ce
soir merci infiniment merci d'avoir reçu
mieux
[Musique]